one thing that you can do to really
improve that immersive feel in projects
is to integrate sound and music
seamlessly as part of the world
having it appear to come from one
direction and then as you turn the
camera seemingly come from another
direction
really helps to sell that feeling of
being a part of a living breathing world
luckily 3.js actually makes this super
easy to do it's tempting to think of
3.js as just a 3d rendering library
considering the vast set of features and
functionality that it's sporting but it
does support 3d audio as well by using
this audio listener api you can quickly
and easily integrate sound or even 3d
positional sound in your projects so the
first thing you need to do is declare a
listener and that represents you in
essence the listener
since most of the time you probably want
to hear things relative to the camera
added as a child of the camera
now to play some audio it's as simple as
a couple lines of code
declare a new three dot audio pass the
listener then declare a loader for the
sound you want and supply this callback
and set the results of the audio object
you created set some stuff like volume
and play
and voila
here we have some music playing but as i
walk around it's always at the same
volume if you wanted to say have an
actual set of speakers in the world
blasting music we can do that easily
this is where you use the positional
audio api
this is nearly identical to the audio
object you created earlier but instead
you create this positional audio object
and there's a couple extra details
these need to be anchored to actual
objects with positions in the world so
add it as a child to a mesh or something
in the world
secondly there's some extra parameters
to play with
i'm just going to set the reference
distance but there's a few others like
the roll-off factor which affects how
fast the volume is reduced the further
from the source you are the distance
model which affects the equation used to
decide how to fall off the further you
are from the source
and you can use the max distance to set
a limit to how far away you can be
or this set directional cone which lets
you make some sort of spotlight but for
sound like a directional speaker
okay we've got our speaker set up in the
middle of the room here and i'm going to
walk up to it i'll shut up now so you
can hear
so that's
working and interestingly if i put the
speaker to the left of the camera
and now to the right
now if you've got stereo speakers or
headphones you should have been able to
hear the sound switch from one ear to
the other that's pretty much enough to
get you going but obviously i didn't
stop there since i also found this neat
audio analyzer class
which gives you back the frequency data
for whatever it is that you're playing
which is really neat
i used that to code up a couple audio
visualizers
so the first thing you got to do is
create some audio analyzers
so i've loaded a couple songs here and
i've created two audio analyzers one for
each
in this loop here i created a whole
bunch of boxes
nothing special or crazy here just
straight up a whole lot of boxes
finally in the step function what we do
is loop over the frequency data
we normalize it to the range 0 to 1 and
then all i do is use that to scale the
mesh
we also use it to fiddle with the colors
a bit using a color spline
by setting the emissive property we can
kind of make them glow for the blocks
that are really scaled a lot
and the second audio visualizer i made
this one purely shader based
so what i did was created a data texture
to take the frequency data from the
analyzer
then in the shader basically what i'm
doing is creating a circle with 2d sdfs
or sine distance functions
and i'll sample the frequency data from
the texture and use that to make the
boxes bigger or smaller and also to
colorize them a bit
most of this code is based on inugo
equiliz's tutorials so i encourage you
to check out his site
and here we go we've got two speakers
with two different songs both on
opposite ends of the area
i'll wander around and check them out if
you're curious about the code it's up on
github until next time cheers
[Music]
you